lots of news to talk about we're gonna
start with this high-ranking Republicans
are telling President Trump to start
acting like a head of state after his
newest Twitter outburst the president
called morning TV host Joe Scarborough
and Mika Brzezinski two of his more
persistent critics crazy Mika and psycho
Joe he also claimed that Brzezinski was
bleeding badly from a facelift when they
met in Florida just after Christmas
Scarborough and Brzezinski responded in
The Washington Post this morning under
the headline Donald Trump is not well
they say the president lied about what
happened at mar-a-lago Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill where lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle are condemning the
president's comments Nancy good morning
good morning the president is used to
being criticized for his tweets but
what's different this time is the
ferocity of the response from
Republicans some of them practically
begging him to knock it off others
calling his comments quote not normal or
beneath the dignity of his office I'm
fine my family brought me up really
tough but I am very concerned as to what
this once again reveals about the
president United States the host of
Morning Joe say the president's Twitter
attack reflects a disturbing pattern of
behavior he for some reason takes things
so much more personally with women he's
so much more vicious with women he
always goes after Mika and it's always
personal with Mika and he packed about
five lies into the tweets on Capitol
Hill yesterday the reaction to mr.
Trump's tweets was swift and bipartisan
tweets like this are inconsistent with
the greatness of the country CEDA means
women but more than that he has the
means himself more than 50 lawmakers
took to Twitter themselves Republicans
asking the President to stop it saying
his comments don't help our national
dialogue urging him to model decency and
respect in the wake of the shooting of
GOP Congressman Steve Scalise believe me
she would not be my first choice during
the campaign mr. Trump mocked the
appearance of women who accused him of
sexual harassment and he attacked the
looks of both of his female opponents
Carly Fiorina
and Hillary Clinton
Maine Republican Susan Collins said the
president is an equal-opportunity
insulter all of us get frustrated at
times but that doesn't mean that we
should strike out with language that
really is not befitting a public
official more than one lawmaker noted
that mrs. Trump has chosen cyberbullying
as a cause in November she was asked
about her husband's Twitter habits on 60
minutes so you never say to him come on
I did of course I did but on Thursday
the first lady defended her husband
saying when he gets attacked he will
punch back
ten times harder this is typically the
time of the morning when we hear from
the president about issues like this but
he has not tweeted yet this morning
Norah about the controversy instead he's
talking about violence in Chicago and
health care all right Nancy thank you so
much